nous passons aux amendements le 83
Monsieur Seguin
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement soutenu par le groupe des
Républicains vise à appliquer au RSA et
à la SS une revalorisation de trois et
demi pour cent au lieu de 4 tel qu'il a
été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
anticipé au 1er juillet 2022 je rappelle
que le RSA et la SS garantissent un
revenu minimum à des personnes sans
emploi en attente d'insertion
professionnelle il n'y a pas lieu de
revaloriser un taux supérieur à celui
des personnes exerçant une activité
professionnelle à mon avis le taux de
trois et demi pour cent et l'équivalent
au taux de revalorisation du point
d'indice de la fonction publique
pourquoi on augmente de 4% alors les
minima sociaux je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi les aides sociales
sont supérieures en revalorisation au
travail
par ailleurs je tiens à rappeler que les
allocations chômage on va valorisées à
2,9%. merci
si en discussion commune le 44 monsieur
Duplomb
oui monsieur le Président je suis
conscient que l'amendement que j'ai
déposé risque encore plus de faire des
bas que celui de Monsieur Seguin puisque
sur mon amendement je dis très
clairement que il faut qu'on se pose
aussi les bonnes questions
quand je suis sur le terrain comme
beaucoup d'entre nous pour pas dire tous
quel est le constat qu'est-ce que nous
entendons nous entendons des entreprises
qui nous disent sans cesse nous nous
trouvons pas les personnes suffisantes
pour occuper les postes qu'on est prêt à
ouvrir j'ai l'exemple par exemple sur
mon département d'une usine de
fabrication de champignons de Paris qui
cherche 60 emplois et qui est obligé de
faire appel à 40 emplois polonais parce
que tout simplement il les trouve pas
sur le territoire de la Haute-Loire
quand je discute avec des gens qui
semblent suffisamment intelligents pour
comprendre les choses il nous disent
quoi Louise mais c'est pas étonnant
puisque aujourd'hui la différence entre
être aux aides sociales ou travailler
n'est pas suffisamment importante et
donc par définition il y a beaucoup de
gens qui se disent à quoi ça sert de
prendre ma voiture pour aller travailler
puisque au bout du bout j'ai presque
autant dans un département comme le mien
j'ai presque autant à rester chez moi
plutôt que d'aller travailler
vise à une revalorisation de 3,5% du RSA
et de la SS pour finalement s'aligner
sur la revalorisation du point d'indice
de la fonction publique alors je vais
pas revenir sur la présentation qui a
été faite très bien faite d'ailleurs par
mon collègue Vincent Segoin puisque
effectivement on a même si l'amendement
présenté des taux identiques pour tous
les minimas on a quand même globalement
des taux qui sont différents pendant
cette période d'inflation on a eu
effectivement des taux sur la re qui est
porté par les partenaires sociaux sur
l'unédique qui sont de 2,9% donc ils ne
sont pas sur les 4%, la Gire Carco le
cpsti fait le choix de ne pas aligner
ses complémentaires et reste à zéro
effectivement il y aurait pu y avoir je
le trouve un intérêt à ce qu'on puisse
un moment donné se poser des questions
sur des revalorisations différenciées
des minimas par anticipation alors le
rapporteur que je suis apporté un avis
favorable en commission à cet amendement
malheureusement nous n'avons pas été
suivi par la commission la Commission a
donc EMI un avis défavorable mais
néanmoins vous comprendrez bien que je
me réserverai à votre personnel sur cet
amendement s'agissant du 44 rectifié le
précédent en n'ayant pas effectivement
été voté par la commission celui-ci il a
bien entendu pas été non plus donc la
Commission a aussi émis un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
c'est un avis défavorable sur les deux
amendements comme je viens d'évoquer un
écho à ce que vient de dire madame le
rapporteur pour dire que concernant
agirco et les retraites complémentaires
les dates de revalorisation sont
différentes les partenaires sociaux sont
saisis de la revalorisation et feront le
choix du niveau de celle-ci à l'occasion
de leur échéance qui doit être de
mémoire au 1er novembre ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose pour
les deux amendements qui ont été
présentés j'ai dit mon opposition j'ai
dit la volonté du gouvernement
d'accompagner l'ensemble des ménages y
compris ceux qui sont bénéficiaires du
RSA au même niveau vous comparez avec le
la revalorisation du point d'indice de
la fonction publique sans tenir compte
notamment du fait que le point d'indice
même s'il n'avait pas été revalorisé
depuis longtemps s'inscrit dans une
grille de rémunération avec un gvt et
une progression de carrière ce qui peut
expliquer cette différence d'un demi
point par rapport à d'autres éléments de
revalorisation et par ailleurs s'il y a
une chose que je peux partager dans ce
que vous avez dit l'un et l'autre c'est
le fait que la priorité des priorités
c'est permettre le retour à l'emploi
c'est ce à quoi je m’emploie et je pense
d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi pour cette
parenthèse que la société n'est pas
quitte de son devoir de solidarité
lorsqu'elle a attribué 575 euros par
mois à un allocataire du RSA la société
l'équipe de son devoir de solidarité
quand elle a assuré ce revenu minimum et
qu'elle a assuré dans le même temps une
offre d'insertion et une possibilité
aussi personnalisée possible de retour à
l'emploi car à mes yeux la seule
autonomie la seule dignité passe par
l'emploi et passe par le revenu du
travail plus que par le simple bénéfice
d'un minima social tel que le RSA en
attendant ce retour à l'emploi qui est
un objectif je ne reviens pas sur les
objectifs de plein d'emplois que nous
avons sur la mobilisation de tous les
acteurs de la formation et l'insertion
nous devons protéger l'ensemble des
ménages est donc nous sommes extrêmement
attachés à ce que cette revalorisation
ne soit pas différenciée au-delà même du
chiffre au-delà même de la différence
parfois d'un demi point dans les
propositions qui sont les vôtres il a
une force symbolique à ne pas traiter
les plus abîmés de nos concitoyens de la
même manière que
merci monsieur le ministre
le président Laurent
oui avec ses amendements moi je trouve
qu'on là on touche à Landes parce que de
quoi on parle là on parle de gens qui
vivent avec quelques centaines d'euros
par mois qui survivent avec quelques
centaines de euros par mois les gens qui
sont RSA et vous nous proposez de
réduire
une augmentation déjà minimale
alors que ces prestations subies
d'ailleurs comme l'ensemble des revenus
des baisses
massives à cause des pertes de pouvoir
d'achat à cause de l'inflation mais ce
que je veux dire surtout c'est que pour
argumenter cette amendement vous nous
dites il faudrait revaloriser le travail
le problème c'est que ces amendements
viennent d'un groupe
qui ne proposent aucune augmentation de
la revalorisation du travail qui refuse
avec le gouvernement toutes les
propositions d'augmentation des salaires
dans le privé c'est à dire que vous êtes
ceux qui refusaient la revalorisation du
travail et vous et vous allez voter ce
projet de loi comme vous l'avez voté à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que
justement sa colonne vertébrale c'est de
ne pas demander un euro aux entreprises
et aux employeurs pour augmenter la
valeur du travail alors ne venez pas
nous faire la leçon sur la
revalorisation du travail pour baisser
des prestations de gens qui survivent à
peine quelques centaines d'euros par
mois alors que vous êtes ceux qui la
refusé la revalorisation du trap merci
chers collègues
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je vais reprendre quasiment
les mots de mon collègue ces amendements
sont pour moi indécents je suis
particulièrement choquée
particulièrement choquée quand on ose
proposer que celles et ceux allocataires
du RSA qui ne seraient pas ne sont pas
en activité professionnelle vous
indiquez même dans un des amendement les
fruits du travail doivent avant tout
être revalorisés mais parce que vous
considérez qu'être un locataire du RSA
c'est un choix que c'est un projet de
vie que de s'inscrire durablement dans
le RSA et comme ça on est bien on n'a
pas besoin de se fatiguer le matin je
reprendrai presque vos mots mais est-ce
que je ne voulais pas le faire mais je
vais le faire est-ce que vous connaissez
le montant du RSA mensuel pour une
personne
575 euros 52 pour une personne comment
peut-on vivre on survie comme cela a été
dit avec ce montant comment peut-on
avoir poser
oser dire que ces allocataires ne
méritent pas une augmentation à minima
de 4%, vous savez combien ça fait 4% en
augmentation j'ai fait l'outil calcul
parce que c'est bien quand on sait de
quoi on parle c'est 23 € et quand on
reste à 3,5 % c'est 20 €. alors
évidemment peut-être que pour vous 3-0
c'est rien du tout mais quand on a si
peu quand on a si peu 575 euros par mois
et bien 3 euros c'est important et ça
peut permettre de manger sur un repas
alors vraiment moi je suis vraiment
choquée qu'on puisse se faire de telles
propositions de non revalorisations nos
alignement au titre des autres
prestations parce que on aurait des
hommes et des femmes qui auraient choisi
délibérément de ne pas travailler et qui
se qui serait satisfait de cette
situation alors vous évoquez la
revalorisation du travail et comme cela
était dit et bien nous le demandons la
revalorisation du travail nous n'avons
eu de cesse de le depuis le début de nos
débats l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation du SMIC on a ce que je
voulais dire et je suis très en colère
merci même la présidente rossignol
à ma présidente aussi
moi je voudrais répondre à notre
collègue du plomb qui nous disait tout à
l'heure je rencontre des gens qui
pensent que je rencontre des gens qui
pensent que il se le matin pour aller
travailler alors qu'il y en a d'autres à
côté qui savent pas et qui gagne autant
que c'est que des gens pensent mais vous
qui est un sénateur dans une enceinte
qui travaille qui connaît les chiffres
vous ne le pensez pas donc la question
c'est pas tant que ce que pensent les
gens que ce que nous devons leur dire
pour rétablir la vérité je pense que par
ailleurs
il y a un problème
il y a un problème effectivement
aujourd'hui du rapport au travail à
l'emploi
c'est vrai et ce mais ce n'est pas une
un sujet français votre point de vue qui
consiste à dire c'est parce que les
revenus de remplacement sont trop élevés
que les gens ne vont pas travailler est
un point de vue qui sortent à la réalité
internationale c'est qu'aux États-Unis
ils ont le même problème et dans
l'ensemble des pays développés le même
phénomène est à l'oeuvre en ce moment et
croyez-moi que les revenus de
remplacement aux États-Unis ça n'a rien
à voir avec les revenus de remplacement
en France donc je ne pense pas que nous
pourrons résoudre ce problème qui est un
problème pour la croissance la création
de richesse dans notre pays le Morat la
santé morale des jeunes générations et
la cohésion nationale incontestablement
mais ce n'est pas en abondance cette
fausse représentation d'un lien direct
entre les revenus de remplacement et le
désamour du travail que nous allons
ensemble régler le problème et puis la
meilleure façon de creuser l'écart entre
les revenus de remplacement et
les salaires pourquoi tout à l'heure
quand on vous a proposé d'augmenter le
SMIC qui est le revenu de salaire le
plus près des revenus remplacements
pourquoi vous n'avez pas voté on vous a
donné une opportunité exceptionnelle de
répondre au sujet que vous soulevez de
l'écart entre revenus remplacement et
salaire donc mes chers collègues je vous
appelle à ce qu'on est une réflexion
plus approfondie sur ce qui se passe sur
la planète dans le pays développé à
l'écart du travail merci cher collègue
madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président sans
concertation je vais vous dire la même
chose que ma collègue Laurent c'est que
mes collègues avant mais peut-être de
manière un petit peu plus un petit peu
moins châtié moi quand je vous entends
j'ai l'impression pas d'être au Sénat
mais d'être au café du commerce
si si
parce qu'effectivement c'est ce que l'on
entend au café du commerce et comme l'a
dit Laurence Rossignol comme l'a dit
Laurence Rossignol ici on est au Sénat
et on a des moyens on a des moyens pour
expertiser ce que l'on pense on a des
moyens pour aller pour aller voir pour
chercher pour on a des études on a tout
ce qu'il faut donc on ne peut pas dire
des choses comme ça quant à ceux qui
vous disent justement que ben ma foi
certains préfèrent ne pas aller
travailler c'est plus facile de
percevoir les minimas sociaux et bien
par exemple est-ce qu'ils se sont mis
dans la peau d'une femme parce que c'est
souvent une femme toute seule avec un
enfant deux enfants toute seule avec un
père qui s'est échappé qui n'assume pas
et ben oui c'est pas la caricature c'est
la vie et avec des emplois qui sont
proposés des emplois des emplois qui
sont proposés
à temps partiel avec des horaires
complètement atypiques donc un salaire
qui est bien loin d'atteindre le SMIC
deuxième possibilité de payer la garde
de ses enfants alors oui ces gens-là
font des comparaisons et je vous dirai
juste que c'est humain et la dernière
chose c'est qu'effectivement pour que
les gens n'aient pas à faire ces
comparaisons-là parce qu'il serait bien
mieux eux-mêmes et ils se sentirait bien
mieux au travail c'est effectivement
d'augmenter les salaires
bien si j'ai un collègue monsieur Segoin
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le Président
les chiffres sont têtus le taux de
chômage en France aujourd'hui est à 7,1%
l'Allemagne l'Italie l'Espagne le
Portugal sont à trois et demi pour cent
le plein emploi moi j'ai toujours appris
que c'était trois et demi pour cent
pas 7,1%
. alors vous proposez toujours de taxer
les entreprises ça fait 30 ans qu'on
entend ça bilan mais ça fait 30 ans ça
fait 30 ans que vous avez la main sur le
cœur que vous êtes choqué et que vous
nous dites il faut taxer les entreprises
continuellement continuons mais regardez
regardez simplement notre balance
commerciale qui est ultra déficitaire
essayez de faire le lien entre le
travail vous dites augmenter le SMIC
mais faites le lien entre le travail et
la balance commerciale et vous
comprendrez que vous détruisez toujours
un peu plus l'entreprise mais continuons
continuons continuons parce que le seul
recours aujourd'hui pour payer tout ça
c'est le recours à la dette alors c'est
sûr aujourd'hui on peut avoir la main
sur le cœur et dire qu'on pense on pense
à ceux qui ne travaillent pas
notre problème on le reporte ce sont nos
enfants qui vont le rembourser ce n'est
pas nous alors si c'est ça d'avoir du
courage en France moi je trouve ça bien
dommage en tout cas je retiens une chose
c'est qu'on revalorise plus les minima
sociaux que le travail et ça je trouve
ça dommage merci cher collègue madame
merci Président j'ai entendu mes deux
collègues dire tout à l'heure qu'il
fallait se poser les bonnes questions
autant je peux comprendre qu'on peut
faire valoir une différenciation de ou
une valorisation différente des
prestations telles qu'elles soient
autant je ne peux pas accepter qu'on
puisse se dire que le RSA ne peut pas
être valorisé à la même hauteur que les
autres prestations personne ne fait le
choix
d'habiter dans un logement social et ne
pas avoir les moyens de payer son
logement social et c'est le cas de plein
de RMS à la Réunion comme c'est le cas
pour l'ensemble des outre-mer et dans
des quartiers de la France hexagonale on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui ne pas traiter
humainement chaque citoyen de la
République française et les
augmentations valent par rapport à ce
qui est inscrit sur ce projet de loi
c'est à comment on doit lutter contre la
vie chère et accompagner ceux qui
rencontrent des difficultés alors si
nous sommes tous présents c'est bien
pour discuter de ce projet de loi mesure
d'urgence pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat il y a bien des citoyens
français ici et ailleurs qui touchent le
RS RSA est-ce que leur pouvoir d'achat
doit être différencié du pouvoir d'achat
de ce qui travaille des travailleurs
peuvent ou d'autres travailleurs ou de
ceux qui sont à la recherche d'un emploi
je crois que non et je crois qu'on se
trompe mais franchement
être républicain être républicaine c'est
bien de se dire que chaque individu a
les mêmes droits les mêmes devoirs aussi
je le dis à chaque citoyen que je
rencontre mais il a aussi les mêmes
droits et sur le pouvoir d'achat il doit
pouvoir attendre de tous les sénateurs
et de tous les députés
la même défense de ses droits et CE et
donc la même valorisation voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire
Monsieur Savary
[Applaudissements]
oui vous savez je crois que dans cette
approche il faut beaucoup d'humilité par
rapport à tout cela et puis je pense pas
ce coronaison se content moi je suis un
élu de la marge je suis un adepte de
Léon Bourgeois du solidarisme
ou je crois que chacun a un devoir
vis-à-vis de la planète et qui doit
rendre quelque chose c'est qu'on sentir
à l'impôt et c'est la notion des droits
et de voir il y a des droits et des
devoirs c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut qu'on arrive à régler ce problème
ou une France complètement divisée entre
ceux qui gagnent de l'argent et qui sont
mécontents parce qu'ils payent trop et
ce qui touchent des allocations de
solidarité qui sont mécontents parce
qu'effectivement ils ne touchent pas
assez donc si on continue comme ça ce
qui est pas de différence on n'arrivera
pas à unir la France donc je pense que à
travers une différenciation on peut
commencer à unir c'est un message qui
dit que c'est pas pareil quand on
travaille que quand on travaille pas
mais faut pas les laisser au bord du
chemin et monsieur le ministre je
partage votre point de vue vous dites
que c'est l'offre d'insertion qui compte
c'est pas tellement le revenu qu'on va
laisser c'est la facilité
présider leur département ils savent
bien comment c'est c'est la facilité de
ne pas faire d'action d'insertion parce
que vous avez plus de sous vous laissez
les gens vous les aidez pas à s'en
sortir pour les aider à s'en sortir il
faut des actions d'insertion or qui paye
le RSA c'est le département et quand il
a payé le revenu du RSA mais il y a plus
de sous pour l'insertion dans mon
département c'est toujours 42 millions
d'euros de recettes les dépenses de RSA
c'est maintenant 100 millions d'euros
sur un budget de 500 millions d'euros
comment voulez-vous avoir l'argent
nécessaire pour aider ces personnes donc
il faut revenir à quelque chose d'un peu
plus cohérent que les départements et
les moyens de faire les actions
d'insertion pour sortir des personnes
des difficultés c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est un signe important de
montrer une différence et je soutiendrai
bien entendu
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues évidemment
monsieur Savary que les départements ont
besoin d'avoir des moyens et des
dotations à la hauteur des enjeux qui
sont face à eux et des fragilités mais
aussi des ambitions que nous avons pour
les plus éloignés de l'emploi pour
qu'effectivement demain ils puissent
accéder à l'autonomie à l'autonomie
professionnelle à une situation qu'ils
aspirent à avoir pour autant est-ce
qu'il faut cet objectif loi que vous
visez le lier à l'augmentation ou non de
4% d'un minima sociale
575 euros pour une personne seule je ne
sais plus quel collègue le rappeler tout
à l'heure moi je sais pas vivre avec ça
vous savez vivre avec ça moi je sais pas
pour autant ça ne les ça n'exonère
personne et aujourd'hui il ne me semble
pas que un seul département en France
n'est pas mis en place un dispositif qui
fasse en sorte d'accompagner chaque
bénéficiaire du RSA dans un parcours de
retour vers l'emploi sauf qu'il y a des
personnes quand il rentre dans ce
parcours qui sont en situation
d'illettrisme qui sont situations de
décalification complète et qu'avant de
pouvoir retourner directement à l'emploi
et bien il faut accéder à toute une
série de solutions de formation
peut-être d'insertion dans des
structures des régies de quartiers etc
oui et ben il faut les moyens mais ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant que la
personne qui malheureusement pas en
situation d'accès à l'emploi directement
on l'a punisse on l'interdisant de
pouvoir nourrir ses enfants décemment
pour autant il faut être exigeant et je
suis d'accord sur le fait et je vais
vous dire dans le département du Nord et
croyez moi ça nous déchire le cœur sur
110000 bénéficiaires du RSA il y a 10
000 allocataires ont deux ans qui ont
quitté le RSA parce que ils avaient la
situation qui correspondait à une offre
d'emploi ils l'ont refusé plusieurs fois
d'affilée ils ont perdu le bénéfice du
RSA et croyez moi ça fait l'objet d'une
analyse sociale et professionnelle fine
malheureusement pour eux ils l'ont perdu
j'en suis bien désolé mais juste pour
vous dire que ceux qui sont bénéficiaire
du RSA aujourd'hui c'est parce que
véritablement ils sont engagés dans un
parcours ce ne sont pas des gens qui se
sont mis à l'abri de d'une disposition
qui les protégé d'aller vers l'emploi ou
de faire un effort sachez bien que là il
s'agit juste de donner les moyens à
chacun de pouvoir subvenir à ses besoins
et là les plus précaires merci cher
collègue monsieur Eno
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je crois que c'est un beau
débat il s'agit pas d'ailleurs de d'un
des sens s'agit pas de politiquement
correct ou incorrect il s'agit de se
poser les questions
c'est normal qu'on se pose la question
de savoir dans ce pays s'il y a
suffisamment d'écart entre les revenus
de la solidarité que les revenus de du
travail ou les revenus de l'assistanat
mais j'aime mieux solidarité
qu'assistana et c'est vrai que c'est un
vrai problème mais la question qui est
posée c'est est-ce qu'on répond à ce
problème en faisant en sorte de diminuer
proportionnellement la revalorisation de
du montant du RSA et en le différenciant
d'autres revalorisations moi je ne le
pense pas sincèrement je vais même aller
plus loin est-ce que ça participe au
retour à l'emploi je ne le pense pas
est-ce que c'est le RSA qui crée la
marginalisation d'une partie de la
société je ne le pense pas
et donc la question c'est le retour à
l'emploi la question c'est la formation
mais il me semble que se poser la
question et donner cette réponse à
l'occasion d'un projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est poser une bonne
question mais c'est trouver une mauvaise
réponse parce que notre société elle est
très très fracturé j'ai bien compris les
les arguments de de René Paul Savary sur
beaucoup de sujets je suis d'accord avec
lui mais pas là parce que si je
comprends bien ce qu'il dit moi j'ai au
fond je suis sensible à son
argumentation même à conclusion est
totalement différente je dis non à la
différenciation pourquoi parce que notre
société elle est terriblement fracturée
et si on envoie ce message là on ne
rassemble pas la société française mais
on accroît la fracture sociale et même
parfois la fracture territoriale et à
mon avis c'est une bonne question mais
donner cette réponse est une mauvaise
réponse je vous remercie chers collègues
alors j'ai encore deux explications de
vote de demande et ensuite j'ai un
scrutin sur l'amendement 83 donc on
passera ensuite au vote
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur le président
mon amendement il vise pas à supprimer
le RSA et encore moins à dire que je ne
connais pas les montants du RSA puisque
je les ai demandé pour les avoir
exactement vous avez raison une personne
isolée c'est 506,46 € avec la
revalorisation ça sera 526 euros 72 par
mois mais ce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre et je pense que là dessus on
peut se poser la question de façon
globale
si la personne qui touche 500 euros
estime que le montant qui touche n'est
pas suffisant
quand on lui propose un emploi à 1300
euros au SMIC minimum 1300 ou 1200
pourquoi pourquoi
mais je pose une question simple
pourquoi là où il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir véritablement une qualification
professionnelle particulière ces emplois
là ne sont pas pourvus et qu'on soit
obligé d'aller chercher obligatoirement
des emplois à l'étranger à un moment
donné si on n'a pas la possibilité de se
poser cette question globalement je
pense qu'on est totalement à côté du
débat alors on peut essayer d'y répondre
ou pourquoi ils ne vont pas chercher cet
emploi parce que le vous le savez qu'au
moins le RSA n'est qu'une partie de ce
qui peut bénéficier parce que si on y
rajoute l'APL c'est plus 526 euros c'est
230 euros de plus ça fait 500 ça fait
750 euros et que si vous avez des gens
en plus de ça qui sont isolés qui vivent
avec une mère isolée avec un enfant
c'est 1300 + 700 c'est 2000 euros par
mois c'est ça la réalité de ce qui se
passe dans les campagnes et chez nous
donc ne pas le regarder ne en train de
regarder en face c'est le nier ne pas
vouloir traiter le problème c'est
continuer de le subir alors que d'un
côté on a des emplois qui sont ouverts
qui pourraient être pris par des
personnes sur lesquelles on donne de
l'aide sociale et qui pourrait permettre
de diminuer le coût pour l'État et de
remettre les gens dans le circuit entre
guillemets du travail alors que c'est
pas ce qu'on fait et on se contente de
faire entrer des étrangers pour prendre
ses postes non pourvu merci chers
collègues madame ponce pour terminer
merci monsieur le Président moi je l'ai
souvent dit je vous conseille un petit
stage d'une semaine chez a été des
carmonde ou à l'abbé Pierre si vous
préférez vous saurez vous serez ainsi
que la trappe à l'emploi la trappe à
l'emploi c'est ce qui a été dit la santé
les problèmes les problèmes de
qualification mais la trappe à l'emploi
c'est la pauvreté c'est le con voilà
c'est ces gens-là ils sont occupés ils
sont occupés à survivre et quand vous
êtes avec 500 euros effectivement vous
passez toute votre énergie à survivre
donc c'est ça rappelez-vous un
économiste l'a dit et ATD Quart Monde le
répète la trappe à l'emploi pour
comprenez ce que ça veut dire de pas
accéder à l'emploi c'est la pauvreté et
puis quand même c'est un véritable
mensonge il faut écouter quand même ceux
qui sont en train de travailler sur le
revenu univers d'activités qui disent
que y compris avec l'APL y compris avec
les allocations familiales le travail
paye excusez-moi la différence elle est
là et depuis la prima l'activité la
revalorisation après les gilets jaunes
c'est le cas et je vais vous dire une
autre chose pour les jeunes de moins de
25 ans ce que vous voulez pas justement
être bénéficiaire parce que c'est vrai
que avec le RSA il y a aucun jeune qui
va travailler et bien à Lyon il y a le
revenu de solidarité jeune oh vous savez
pas c'est pas extraordinaire 300 à 400
euros il n'en reste pas moins que 1/3
est déjà sorti un tiers est déjà sorti
du dispositif ils ont été effectivement
accompagnés et ils ont été aidés pour ne
pas passer son temps leur temps à
s'occuper à survivre alors et une
dernière chose par rapport à la
revalorisation des salaires si il y
avait pas eu cette déflation salariale
s'il y avait pas eu de plus en plus des
travailleurs pauvres c'est-à-dire qu'on
travaille et qu'on n'y arrive pas on
travaille et on est pauvre et bien il y
aurait moins ce que vous prétendez
effectivement ne peuvent pas vouloir
c'est à dire que les travailleurs
l'écart donc merci chers collègues j'ai
encore j'ai encore trois demandes
honnêtement je pense que on a on a pas
mal débattu du sujet il y a beaucoup de
collègues qui sont exprimés donc je
donne encore trois fois la parole et
ensuite j'arrête non non j'ai déjà les
trois non non
on ne va pas avancer du tout on peut on
peut passer toute la soirée dessus et
allez le président Retailleau
bien mes chers collègues jusqu'à présent
je pense qu'on a donné de ce débat une
autre image que celui qui a pu avoir
cours à l'Assemblée nationale mais je
comprends que ce sujet là puisse
s'enflammer
nos débats je pense que il ne doit pas y
avoir de débat interdit je voudrais
simplement répéter et redire peut-être
différemment un certain nombre de nos
convictions la première chose personne
bien sûr n'a dit que quelqu'un vit
correctement avec 575 euros avec 4% de
plus non plus mes chers collègues
personne non plus n'a dit que les gens
qui étaient au RSA avaient choisi de
l'être mais je sais parce que j'ai été
président de départements comme d'autres
parmi nous je sais parfaitement
qu'il y a des gens qui touchaient le RSA
qui touchent le RSA qui sont des
victimes qui ont du mal être employées
et d'autres qui peuvent se compler dans
une situation
vous le savez parfaitement tout seul et
tous ceux qui ont été président
département le savent ils nous est
arrivé d'ailleurs de stopper des
contrats
lorsqu'ils n'étaient pas honoré parce
que il y a la règle c'est le droit et il
y a des devoirs première chose la
deuxième chose la fracturation mais la
fracturation le RSA a été déjà bien sûr
revaloriser 1,8 pas l'agir Carco j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure zéro en juillet
monsieur le ministre ce sera moins de 3%
vous le savez très bien moins de 3% au
mois de novembre prochain l'indemnité
chômage c'est moins de 3%.
2,9%. donc ce sujet de l'écart entre le
revenu du travail et le revenu
substitution il est là il est important
il est devant nous et il faudra
absolument qu'on le traite et nous avons
ici proposé de revaloriser de travail la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires pérennisées quelqu'un
qui fait de 36 à 39 avec la
défiscalisation
et nous la revalorisation c'est par le
travail qu'on obtient mes chers
collègues sinon c'est de la monnaie de
singe merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur gay
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
d'abord le RSA est en droit et moi j'ai
un débat avec Monsieur rotaillon je l'ai
déjà entendu il y a pas les droits et
les devoirs
le texte fondateur
texte fondateur notre République c'est
la Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen et les devoirs sont cités
qu'une fois dans le préambule les
devoirs
une fois les droits ils sont naturels et
imprescriptibles et ils sont
préexistants au contrat social et une
fois qu'il y a un droit on doit en
garantir son accès ça c'est un premier
débat la deuxième chose
sur le RSA moi c'est il faut nous dire
dans quelle société vous voulez vivre ou
nous expliquer donc qu'il faut pas
revaloriser le RSA qui est un droit à
survivre avec 500 et quelques suivant
les situations ça peut monter à 600 ou
700 mais même avec des enfants 600 ou
700 euros et je crois que personne dira
ici qu'on peut vivre dignement c'est
survivre et vous nous proposez durant
toute la première partie de ne pas
revaloriser non plus le travail
et un certain nombre ici vous l'ont dit
il y a eu beaucoup d'occasions de
revaloriser le travail donc on aura
passé tout en débat sur mesure d'urgence
pour la protection du pouvoir d'achat
vous voulez pas la revalorisation des
minima sociaux vous voulez pas la
revalorisation du travail donc on vous
demande dans le moment de crise dans
lequel nous vivons quel est votre projet
de société si vous voulez même pas
protéger celles et ceux qui n'ont rien
mais aussi même pas les travailleurs et
les travailleuses de ce pays et là vous
êtes en pleine contradiction parce qu'on
vous en a laissé beaucoup d'occasions et
à chaque fois vous n'avez pas pris la
même tendue et donc ça on sera vous le
rappeler au moment du vote final
merci chers collègues madame Garnier
oui merci monsieur le Président
justement très rapidement parce que j'ai
entendu le ministre Olivier du soft ce
matin sur Europe 1 qui nous parlait
justement du RSA et qu'est-ce qui nous
dit il nous dit aujourd'hui nous avons
presque 2 millions d'allocataires du RSA
c'est deux fois plus qu'il y a 10 ans
deux fois plus qu'il y a 10 ans la
situation n'est pas satisfaisante donc
voilà moi je voudrais prolonger les
propos de mes collègues partout les
entreprises cherchent à embaucher
partout il y a des postes qui sont non
pourvus et on a deux fois de plus de
bénéficiaires du RSA qui a 10 ans donc
bien sûr qu'il y a des personnes qui ont
besoin de ces aides sociales bien sûr
qu'il ne faut stigmatiser personne mais
je crois que c'est aussi notre
responsabilité de voir la réalité en
face et de nous poser les bonnes
questions
merci chers collègues donc je vais
mettre aux voix l'amendement 83 j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de ce que tu as
publique par le groupe RDPI sur cet
amendement je vous rappelle que la ville
de la commission défavorable avec le
gouvernement défavorable il doit être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par un type 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
et maintenu monsieur Segoin il est
Mathieu l'amendement
le 44 sera retiré
très bien
par des bandes de vote non le scrutin
est clos
voici le résultat du Scotland 129 sur
l'amendement 83 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordée par les sénateurs groupe
politique et notifié à la présidence
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 329 pour l'adoption
144 contre 185 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]